Mike Tirico is going into the Hall of
Fame as well segue Mike host and Bay
eces coverage of the Kentucky Derby I
don't know why he just went there this
Saturday May 5th the 2:30 Eastern on NBC
good morning Mike I just walked into a
hallway this may be the only home I get
into but that'll be fine yeah you're
100% right on witness he was a real
blocker in the days of tight ends were
asked to block earlier he definitely is
way above his stats for his performances
don't you think with baseball I used to
always think okay was this guy at the
best four years at his position yeah
and for many years I thought Winton was
among the best of the consistency of it
whereas Brandon Marshall very good but
overshadowed by some other guys at that
position during that time so I'm I'm
right there with him
but also you're trying to gauge now what
his Hall of Fame worthy when it comes to
catches even even quarterbacks we expect
you to throw for 4,000 yards now if you
don't throw for 30 touchdowns you've had
a bad year with a wide receiver if you
don't get 90 catches that somehow you've
had a subpar season what is this going
to do to guys who have respectable
numbers and then you have this new wave
where Antonio Brown can end up second or
third on the all-time reception list sir
it's to me a bit of a sliding scale and
I come back to that instead of comparing
numbers because even in five year
increments the numbers can change
because of an evolution of the game or
the easy access passes like the bubble
screens and those types of things at
least if you look at okay during his
time where was he relative to the other
players at his position then it balances
out a statistical oddity for a year or
two maybe they threw a guy a hundred ten
ball under ten completions we threw him
160 balls in the year and he caught 115
because the other receiver was hurt or
they had a running game that was not as
good so they had to throw it it down sit
out when you say okay was this guy
excellent his position was he elite
among his peers in his position and when
other teams had to go up against him did
you put his name up on the board and say
we've got to control this guy we've got
to stop Dan Patrick in this game it
not its be your old line we can only
hope to contain him because he's going
to get his those are the kind of guys
that separate from just a whole volume
of analytics and stats what is Tom Brady
saying the other night to Jim Gray that
was pretty interesting there's there's
odd messaging going back and forth even
to the Dean on answer that we still are
getting on Malcolm Butler don't know if
we'll ever get an answer so but there's
something under the surface there and I
I don't know what it is I don't know if
it goes back to the Garoppolo trade and
all the other stuff we had heard that
lengthy article that was written in
December of last year but for some
reason you know three very talented
terrific championship-level people at
those key spots in the NFL owner GM /
head coach because Belichick is really
both and quarterback and you need that
triumvirate to be great to have a great
run as an organization for some reason
it seems like everybody's just trying to
grab their little piece of the earth
here and not work as one as much as they
did but look they're still they're still
supreme and when it comes down to that
moment they put it together the problem
was and the Super Bowl is you know
you're there it was the ability to stop
Philadelphia it wasn't the offenses
fault my brady through 500 yards you
know I still think it's not going to
impact the performance but something's
going on there I'm glad Tom said look I
still do want to play into my 40s is it
quiet that conversation a little bit I'm
just trying to figure this out that
Brady says he feels unappreciated but
really this is about Belichick and he
doesn't feel loved as much because they
have surrounded him every single year
they've made sure that he has a
competitive team they got rid of
Garoppolo as the report or rumors
suggested that you know he felt the
competition there so I I don't know and
look I I know that we love to people
critique what I do every day and I
understand it and I'm gonna critique Jim
Gray here but I have to single this out
I can't make it they don't appreciate
you
it's who is the they in here with the
pages because I want him to
a it's Belichick you know bill doesn't
forgive me as much love as he needs to
because I do think the rest of the
organization has over the years and and
all the fans do and the league and his
peers do they still speaker brady in
glowing terms and more glowing terms
than any football player playing at the
age of 40 has ever heard from his peers
around the league and NFL Network's
doing the whole top 100 thing where's
Brady gonna be one two three we're just
who knows but that's 40 it's it's insane
what do you really remove yourself Bill
Belichick shows love to no one in those
terms and they go out and say god he's
great you know always one of my buzz
words with Belichick when he describes
players whether it's draft or players he
has it's smart and talking about players
they're smart that's like the bouquet
that you get from Belichick his check
mark of approval if you will he never
goes out of his way and gives you all
the glowing terms about guys and perhaps
it has some of the underlying seeds of
the Tea b12 and the Train a and other
players wanting to do more with Brady's
trainer and getting him off the team
plane and and all that stuff which I
don't pretend to understand the lengths
and depths that mattered but but I did
laughs when Gronkowski is now randomly
thrown out the word pliable in an
interview here which speaks right to the
whole Brady stuff like okay there's a
there's a lot of wink wink little
message little nod going on here is
pretty funny yeah I just I don't know
how much longer it lasts it just doesn't
feel like Tom's gonna be playing into
his mid-40s here I just I don't I don't
see that happen see right you can always
tell yourself doesn't want to keep
playing much longer I saw some of that
the whole time versus time saying it you
get that sense but he still loves that
competition he's so great he threw for
500 yards of the super he's the MVP so
so why not I'm disappointed being here
at the Derby that Gronk is not here
there was a horse remember Gronkowski
yeah I was supposed to be in the Derby
developed a bit of a fever and so you
can't run them here and they hope to
bring them back perhaps for the Belmont
but as you might know that we have a
whole bunch of people were on the air
for almost five hours on NBC Johnny Weir
is part of our covering and my only my
only suggestion was I wanted Johnny
we're interviewing Gronk at the Derby I
thought that would have been television
at its all-time finest he's Mike Tirico
joining us from Churchill Downs NBC's
coverage of the Kentucky Derby Saturday
and that's May 5th starting at 2:30
Eastern on NBC what is it about this
Derby because I haven't heard much of it
I think that most of the I guess
reporting or headlines had to do with a
horse named Gronk is you know wait what
is where's the the buzz here with the
Derby so the people who know and I don't
pretend to be one of the wise guys the
rail birds I follow the sport a little
more over the last couple years doing
this there is a deep field of quality
horses Jerry Bailey and Randy Moss grew
up on the set with me for the coverage
we were talking about this last night as
many as eight horses have a legitimate
chance in their minds to win the race
and that's significantly more you know
sometimes you say well it's a it's a
pretty balanced field sometimes that's
cover four well there aren't really
great horse or really good horses here
this has depth of really good horses
seven or eight justify is the one that
has been stuck out and jumped out the
most and and two of the faces of the
sport are part of the human connections
with Mike Smith Hall of Fame jockey
who's only won one Derby and Bob Baffert
and we've seen the Baffert silver hair
at so many big weird circles over the
years but he was not in the Derby didn't
have a horse in the Derby last year so
he's back and he's got the favorite
justify how much do you bet on Saturday
so last year I thought about it and I
didn't because it was my first time
doing the show the show is you know this
show is massive and you went through the
Super Bowl pregame and you know how long
it was for four-and-a-half hour shows
can be this is just about that long with
the races going on in the middle of it
and I was just too overwhelmed to be
worrying about betting but then I kind
of thought maybe if I'm involved in
trying to bet a little bit maybe I'll be
following it even closer
so I'll probably and I put down a wager
on the Derby but not much why I'm not
Eddie Olczyk and I'm not the boxing
trifectas and looking for super factors
all that stuff maybe I'll put 20 bucks
down just for entertainment purposes
only I remember covering the Preakness
in the Belmont in the 80s mid 80s and I
and I found programs in my attic I went
through and I'm supposed to clean out my
attic and so I went through and I found
all of this stuff and I kept everything
from that and I even mark down the
program of how much I was betting I won
$48 one year on the Belmont so I went to
cash and an Andrew buyer the legendary
handicapper with a Washington Post he
went in front of me and I will say that
he had quite a few more numbers attached
to his winning bet than I did so I think
he I think he may have won over a
hundred thousand dollars and I was next
because I thought I got $48 that I won
on the Belmont one year and he went and
cashed and had I and over $100,000 well
you know one of the big things the whole
sports world is influenced by analytics
and stats and the buyer speed figures
are one of the real base stats analytic
stats that people reference to talk
about and it's in the Daily Racing Form
so people look at them all the time so I
guess that's why they're the buyer speed
figures and not the Patrick speak yes
yes you don't want that it is there but
but have we broken it down it feels like
every other sport we've really broken it
down with the analytics certainly
baseball is horse racing there yet I
know that they've been more numbers
driven than any other sport probably
when trying to break this down but is
there a breakthrough there there are
more you know there's a lot of grass and
different things I've come across just
in the last year of really getting there
two years now really get involved in
this more people who do more analytics
if you really pull back when you look at
the racing for it's such an art to read
learn how to read the racing for me I
hope if if you are involved in sports at
all you've taught your kids
to read the form because it is pretty
neat there's so much analytics and stats
baked into there it probably was an
early driver of such mmm and I think now
the layover that the depth of
understanding and tracking sires and
mayor's and the whole breeding process
on top of it a sport that really had a
great base in analytics they're just
adding to with the modern sensibility
you know Dan at at my alma mater at
Syracuse there's a school of sport
management that's named after David Falk
who was the give the giver for a name
going on the school and in that school
there's now a major in sport analytics
so you can now major in at Alexia magic
we were kids the way we would devour
like box scores out of the Sporting News
if we can go to school a major and a
little we we were not born at the right
time that would have been great can you
mention on Saturday that a horse has a
high motor mic that'd be kind of nice is
there a horse who has a high motor a
higher motor than some of the other
horses you know you're gonna ask you for
passion buckets because that you know in
this sport bucket passion you can kind
of work that in a little bit too if you
can drop a passion bucket that always
resonates but I'd like if you can put
$10 on minor my boy Jack thirty to one
my boy Jack yeah ten bucks on my boy
Jack I'm good for it I will do it and I
will I will make sure that I get the
ticket sent to you and Fritzi so you
guys could post it and put it on social
media
hi bud have fun this weekend all right
that's Mike Tirico for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
ass
[Music]